welcome to the afternoon session to the
first afternoon session I hope you all
enjoyed your lunch in this session we're
gonna talk about how we can make AI
product developers more productive and
it's a session where we have a panel at
the end and we if you're interested
we're really interested in some in some
audience questions as well my name is
Marcus Weimer and with me here Sarah
Burt we are co-chairing this session I
come from the azure data world so the
database world we build databases and
allergic prog tools and data governance
systems and Sarah comes from AI if I get
my mic to work here okay so as Marcus
said I come from a jury I and that is an
organ 'm for sort of a collection of do
AI developer tools on top of azure so
largely this covers something that i
think many people have heard of the
cognitive services where we're taking
sort of new algorithms and models and
making them available to people through
api's we also build our machine learning
which is our suite of developer tools
and we also work on knowledge mining and
specifically as your search so Marcus
and I are just going to give a little
primer on we wanted the session to be
focused on what do we see is sort of the
big challenges in making something that
AI something that many people can
develop as opposed to right now where
it's a very expert driven sort of
bespoke situation every time and so
we're going to talk a little bit about
what we see in ml in practice and sort
of open problems we see and then we're
going to have each of our visitors give
their point of view on kind of what the
future looks like and then we can
discuss that in a panel so I'm gonna
briefly talk us through sort of the
point of view of ml in practice as
someone who's working on making sort of
tools for it so because we all know a
huge part of the story is building
models and I think for for context for
the rest of the things I'm going to say
I'm just going to tell you that what
we've built is infrastructure that
really brings together the end-to-end
story of developing machine learning we
have specific tools in kind of each of
these different spaces or we work with
open source tools and I think the team
has put amazing effort I'm you know very
proud of what we have and it's nowhere
near where we need to be and so a lot of
the comments coming forward are you know
context from building these different
tools and working with customers on them
but also understanding that you know
we're very far from where we need to be
so the first thing I want to say is
especially if you're coming from
academia there's an incredible focus on
this step like you would think that all
of machine learning is just this step of
building and training models and in
reality there's a step that comes before
that you actually need to you know get
data and prepare it and give data to
your models and in industry when teams
are surveyed a lot of them say they
spend a lot more time on this step than
they do on sort of building and training
of course once you've built in trainer
model there's another step which turns
out to be a whole giant nightmare as
well which is actually deploying this
model and deploying this model in an
application in your production needs and
so doing all of this together
is a big challenge and it turns out
these really aren't the only steps so
this in fact kind of a hidden step zero
which is one that we face every day
which is helping people understand does
machine learning even work for my
problem is this something I could use
machine learning for and then if the
answer if someone tells them the answer
to that is yes how do you coax your
problem into being a machine learning
problem and so this is actually the step
where many many people get stuck on
before they even get to the nice chart
that I showed you but if we go back to
kind of the main you know technical
steps as we know them let's talk about
preparing data so it's you know a lot
more than just kind of getting the data
and putting
data set right there's actually a pretty
complex set of operations where you're
trying to ingest the data you're trying
to feature eyes it you're trying to join
it wrangle it etc transform it and well
there's certainly some interesting work
in this space I think there's just huge
gaps at every single one of these steps
in terms of figuring out how do we make
this more automatic how do we make this
more useable how do we make it integrate
it like how do I feature eyes in a way
that's actually good for the particular
model I'm choosing or how do I choose a
model that's good for the features so a
lot of actually bringing all of these
pieces together and making them sort of
intelligent and usable the next step and
Marcus is going to talk a lot more in
detail about on specific problems and
how we see them but you know the next
step build and train there's of course
let me see if C I don't know how to use
my animations so right there's also a
ton here it's a lot more than just like
selecting a model and training a model
and of course we've had a ton of
innovation in helping people find the
right models helping people train models
faster you know and more efficiently how
to automatically tune hyper parameters
but I think this space is still kind of
wide open in an area that we care a lot
about particularly for customers is kind
of this area of auto ml right how do we
make this a lot more accessible there's
also just the challenges of debugging
and testing and understanding
understanding trade-offs for other
features not just sort of accuracy and
performance but what if I also care
about bias so there's there's quite a
lot here the last step deploy so if we
want to deploy our model there's
actually quite a few steps to this and
this is where you know we've spent a lot
of our time you need to package the
model in a way that it can actually be
put in an application you need to deploy
it and then what
is out there it's not just you're not
done with it right it's actually a
living breathing thing that needs to
monitor you need to make sure it's
actually doing the right thing in the
application that it doesn't change data
doesn't drift so there's a bunch of
things that need to happen there and
there's actually a similar to the mean
of step zero there's actually a major
step forward this process like we spend
a lot of time going through it once but
it turns out if you really want to use
machine learning in production you need
to go through it over and over again in
a programmatic way and so then it turns
into how do I do this in a way that
includes automated testing automated you
know integration development running
things when I get new data and so we
really want to go from something that
looks more less like this and where it's
one step at a time
but something where it's a living system
where we're just automatically going
through each of these different phases
and so bringing so this is kind of the
ultimate challenge in that this takes
all of the problems at every single
stage and then we need to figure out how
to solve each of them and we need to
figure out how to do them in a way that
is automated if we could solve this
problem we could also do our L a lot
better because this is one of the
reasons that our L is often hard as it
is automatically closing this loop so
now I'm going to hand it over to Marcus
who's actually going to talk in very
specific details about more open issues
thank you so the the key challenge is
that machine learning models are
software artifacts they have to behave
and be like software artifacts when they
get deployed right because we want to
audit them we want to debug them and all
of that at the same time there are
outcomes of data processes and data is
murky and challenging and has lots of
compliance issues and all of that and
it's kind of the key frustration that
our users experience is that this kind
of really it's a really difficult
minefield to navigate so I'm going to go
in way more text heavy slides about some
of those challenges all right as Sara
mentioned we're basically most users
fail is can I take my business problem
and phrase it as a machine learning
problem is this a good idea yes or no is
there another way that would
be better right because if he could ride
software you shouldn't use machine
learning all right
we've tried this with image data with
face detection and stuff didn't work so
we do machine learning but this is a
complete art and from a research
perspective my question is this sounds a
lot like similar to software engineering
in like the 80s or before right but then
we had the Gang of Four
we had software design patterns we
figured things out and stuff that right
now is utterly boring like building a
database client used to be hard and what
is the step function that we can build
together as a community to solve this to
make standard problems addressable in a
standard way
then of course auto ml is an active
research area in this field if you know
it's solvable by machine I mean what do
you do next well you want to build a
pipeline most of the act the current
work very recent work notwithstanding
focuses on the question of given a
pipeline tune the hyper parameters in
practice I don't find that as compelling
because in many cases carefully tuned
defaults compare favorably to a hyper
parameter search so what's more
challenging for for users is how do I
get from domain object or let's say a
database tuple to a feature vector like
automatic feature ization is I think a
very fruitful area to make people way
more productive now of course this is a
bit cheeky Lee formulated better and
fewer programming languages what I mean
where that is let's say to you use
tensor flow and use tensor flow be
forwarding to you write a Python program
that evaluates to a tensor flow program
that gets interpreted by a C++ runtime
that uses various hardware and
throughout that process nice people at
Google and in the tensorflow community
made sure that the thing that you called
a in your Python code is still called a
in the error message that the CUDA
kernel throws and sometimes it isn't so
this is clearly a problem if you have to
go through three four language layers of
different languages just to express your
machine learning model that's what I
mean with better and fewer languages
clearly there is not one that we could
use today the Julia people might
disagree with me on that statement but
this is an interesting area of future
work in my mind
the last one is of course model model
understanding and debugging right what I
mean by that is we already have some
works right some of it came out out of
heat up just across the lake
on understanding specific instances of a
model all right
but how do I then say my predictive
model told me this dimension of my
feature vector is indicative of this
decision how do I relate that backwards
through the feature extraction pipeline
how do I know that this particular
dimension of my feature vector was
actually a collection of words in my
word embedding model all right yes
theoretically we can pipe this through
but in practice we really don't have
really good tools for that so this
relationship between raw data and back
to decision-making is completely
unsolved in my mind another group of
open issues that I think could use some
some more research is this whole
automation of the process all right we
have very mature thank goodness
processes to build software to test it
to deploy it to pull it back to roll it
back and they work most of the time and
I can say this because whenever they
don't work it's a major news in the for
the day all right when any of the big
cloud providers has an outage which
happens so rarely it is major news which
means that hundreds of times thousands
of times it goes right before it goes
wrong we have nothing like that for the
machine learning workflow if I have a
distribution drift that goes so slowly
that I can't detect it as part of my
data tests if I have data tests things
fail and they will fail in spectacular
ways and that will be terrible and I
have no way of knowing this and we need
better software here similarly in the
deployment area all right right now the
state of the art and and we do really
well at this as Microsoft is take your
Python script that is your prediction
prediction engine stick it into a docker
container deploy it to kubernetes now if
you go to a medium-sized bank with an IT
department of five and you tell them hey
machine learning is easy you need a
Koopa Nettie's cluster learn docker
deploy this thing in Python
they look at you and say well but all of
our software is written in Java and
that's what we know like how does this
work how does not compute what you're
saying all right so there are clearly
some some challenges here right and
there are some answers right one answer
is coming from us and encounter a couple
of partners in onyx and other answers in
the room is chunky and TVM there's like
there's options here but I said I don't
think any of them are fully developed
yet
then of course performance is always an
issue it's especially an issue if you
have models that they need to target
many different devices I don't know how
many of you have used Microsoft teams
Microsoft teams has a feature where they
can blur the background all right
for a machine on it is kind of a pretty
straightforward thing detect the face
everything that's not the face make that
blurry now imagine the the sheer variety
of hardware this needs to work on and
work on well and work on well with in
latency constraints because you don't
want choppy video just because the other
person has a slow processor all right so
this is a phenomenal challenge which
advanced organizations like Microsoft
and our competitors can solve clearly
but it's not something that that average
companies can solve how do I get my
machine learning model to have
predictable performance across various
hardware is super hard and we see this
right even today the the dominant way to
do things on GPUs is do it through CUDA
it's a single vendor solution this means
that we as a community haven't fully
understood this problem into such a
level that we can do a multi vendor
solution then of course this is a
personal pet peeve of mine that I've hit
personally a while ago once you deploy
models right when you deploy software
the software is deterministic and a
person uses it and if they send you a
back report that back report is because
the version of the software had the
problem in machinery model say these
living breathing things that you deploy
that learn from user behavior but that
user behaviors influenced by other
models you can only click on ads that
you've been shown you can only go to
pages that were in the search results
and all of that and everyone in like the
on the big online companies is very
aware of this problem I'm not
a really good solution that truly allows
us to model this relationship between
the user the model and the data they
generate that through a user we generate
new training data for other for other
models and the last thing that I wanted
to highlight as a kind of a big area of
problems that I see is we want to be
responsible about this just like we got
really responsible with software design
and only very rarely do we see
catastrophic results in software we want
to have the same thing in our machine
learning systems all right we want to be
able to go to a machine learning system
and say I want to audit this system how
does it make decisions now this is
challenging because I have to go from
the application code the software to the
model to the underlying data now if you
try to do this in an inner deployed
model you might find that you don't even
have that that chain anymore you no
longer know what version of the software
is shipping with what model trained on
exactly what data alright there's a bit
of an embarrassing fact and most data
scientists say oh and in my organization
this isn't happening we are way better
than this but still today this is
happening and it's a it's a very common
concern all right because we don't have
established standards like my software
lives in git and I lock they get hash
whenever I start my software done
I know exactly what version of the
software is producing these decisions
for machine learning we don't have that
we don't even have version numbers right
for software we have semantic version
like a dot B dot C if a increments you
know all that's off it might be a
different piece of software in models we
don't have this and of course then the
flip side of doing auditing is if it
goes wrong you need to know why if some
some consequential decision went wrong
you need to be able to say who did I
made make a poor modeling choice did I
fold the label into my feature set by
accident or something like that
is it the data that truly suggests a
certain behavior that was for instance
the case in the slightly racist Twitter
bot that Microsoft had awhile ago the
data that it was fed with by the Twitter
community was pretty bad or is it a
statistical fluke models are very
impressive in the air
but in the instance they make terrible
mistakes like the one of the recent
winners of imagenet that misclassifies
plastic Turtles for assault rifles if
you hold the turtle in just the right
way so this there is a real problem here
right where you can't attribute a
decision to something that someone did
that's terrifying because then you can't
correct it and I think that needs a lot
of careful research from the whole
community so I hope that we hear hints
at answers for some of those and maybe
others that we missed when when we were
getting together and thinking about what
our what our customers really struggle
with from our panel we have four
distinguished speakers starting with
design he's at ETH where he's leads the
ds3 lab and I know him through his work
on doing CI cd4 machine learning models
and kind of bringing this model testing
and unit testing a little bit closer
together he'll talk about his work there
matías area he's we all know him as the
creator of spark more recently he's been
working on ml flow which is the thing
that I'm personally quite interested in
which allows for logging of machine
learning experiments and also capturing
of models with some iterator janky is a
currently still I believe a PhD student
across the lake at u-dub but he's gonna
join CMU soon as as professor there and
for those of you in the room who are
data scientists you've used his work
because he has been the co-creator of MX
net of XG boost and TVM so he's been
quite prolific and in his career so far
and lastly we have Gustavo Alonso who's
also joining us from ETH in Switzerland
and he has a very long career I can't
really talk about all of it because
really I don't remember but the the part
that I got really excited about is this
and I only and I must admit this I only
understood this last January at a at a
at an event there is why I FPGA school
for machine learning and that's because
you can do things that are not for
norman architectures on them and stuff
that is sequential in for norman
architectures is not necessarily
sequential in those architectures and I
hope he will share some ideas around
hardware for machine learning with us
with that I'd like to hand it over to
say as our first speaker
okay so everyone so in the next seven
minutes as I promised Marcus so I'm
going to kind of summarize what we have
been working on over the last three
years right so over the last three years
myself and my group has been actually
working on like one question that is how
can we make machine learning systems
more usable for non-expert users so what
do I mean by that but now it's per users
I mean those colleagues that we have in
university they're astronomers
biologists social scientists people
predict the Weiser's right so we try to
make sure they can actually use machine
learning for their own specific tasks if
you look at those users right so they
are expert in their own specific domain
but they have never been through the
formal process of using they'd have
never been through the formal training
process of machine learning and computer
science by making a system usable our
goal is really try to make sure all
those users can build their own
machinery applications from scratch all
by themselves
so I have no idea about what answer is
but let me kind of share with you a
little bit about our journey and about
how we think what a problem change or
the last three years so at a very very
beginning so what we in to work on is
pretty clear because if you look at
three years or four years ago so the
system bottleneck is very clear that
motion engine used to be extremely slow
if you try to get a machine on the cloud
just like four years ago right so all
you can get the machine give you one to
ten teraflops but if you look at what
you can get today you can actually
easily get something if you are doing
the right thought into an operation you
can get something that has one pedal for
but in a single box and on that box you
are able to turn pretty decent a neural
network on imagenet in just like five
hours but it wouldn't case like three or
four years ago so that is why you
actually see a whole bunch of people
from our community from motion during
community and including ourselves really
try to like three or four years ago try
to understand how can we put together
all those pretty big boxes and how can
we speed up and scale up machine
learning training process
if you look at today right so speed is
still huge problem even on a pretty
small data set like 100 gigabyte of text
right rhenium was nearing Madoka's do
take weeks on class or GPIOs but we also
start to see users who are actually not
bonded by speed anymore if you talk to
apology is only a half like muhammad saw
the images speed is not their concern
anymore
as of today so what's next right your
speed is necessary for a system to be
useful and to be usable but there's not
a sufficient condition so next season
bottleneck that we realize it's actually
about automation that is even if you
have a system that's very very fast many
of our users they are still overwhelmed
by a number of choices to make when they
build emotion during application even
even if the judgment to build a human
classifier on image night something to
choose between all those family of
models and for each of those model we
need to two more open or hyper parameter
either for architecture or into human
hybrid parameter for the Trillian
process and what makes sense worse is
motion Ernie is an area that keep
getting updated every single day there
may be 10 or 20 papers that our user
want to try and these are just about
models if you think about the into an
emotion learning paper you are actually
asking a biologist to choose all the way
from data denoising feature extraction
high-performance union model selection
mode re-tag research right if they get
lucky they get something useful but they
are all addressed right so highly likely
they are going to make some wrong
decision in the middle and get a model
does not even use what all so that's why
you see a whole bunch of people actually
try to focus on how to automate every
single step in this process if you look
how all of the major cloud service
providers they have their own oto mo
systems and the whole point of startup
try to focus on automation and we also
have our own small system they're
connected players if you look at today
automation is do a huge problem because
like like like forethought of those like
different stages we do not even
understand what is and what is a good
search space right so not to say what is
the optimal social algorithm
for that stage but we also start to see
users who can actually be served
relatively well by existing auto immune
systems you start to see users who can
drag and drop their data set and get
some lotion on him back so what's next
right so human the user have a perfect
autumn our system and this infinite
number of GPUs like what should we focus
on as a next type of usability so the
next step I think again like in my
opinion it's about scenes that actually
be on speed and beyond automation if you
think was to be an automation they are
actually solving something that you are
you want a system to do on day one you
get a task right so on day one you want
to build emotional application you get a
data set your goal is actually try to
get some model as fast as possible right
so we sent sure at this step you care
about speed you care about automation
but your job doesn't finish after day
one right if you really want to motion
your application to be useful to to have
the same quality requirement that your
application need right so starting from
day two you are actually try to get in a
sequence or models that keep getting
better and better and on day two you
start to care about a different
collection of questions you cares about
how to understand the role model to make
sure you can debug the model and try to
think about what twist I should do to
get a better model you need to have a
systematic way to improve the model you
to monitor and provider like I could get
guidance from the user about what to do
next
and you need to want to have a system to
manage the whole workflow but even
before they want there's something you
need to do right because before you
start to use machine learning for your
application you cannot need to
understand whether as you even start
emotion learning products or not right
so untain zero essentially you care
about since like feels beauty study
Cindy check whether I have the right
amount of data or right type of data to
support my motion on your application so
in our opinion the problem for day zero
and day two is actually at least
equally important than the sins that the
user want to do on day one and at least
for us it took it took us embarrassing
amount of time and here we realize that
it actually took us two and a half years
before we realized that they 0 and they
2 is actually equally important problem
so if you really focus on T 0 and they -
there's a whole bunch of interesting
questions that you can actually start to
answer right for example on day zero you
can actually try to understand why there
is no systematic way for you to answer
the question for the user that do I have
the right data for this emeral task if
you care about they like day two you can
actually start to think about how to do
continuous integration and deterrent
like for emotional in task how to do
like profiling of overfitting behavior
for your emotional in task and we are
actually pretty excited about
essentially like this like this
collection problems and some of them
help paper some of them we are still
working on that I don't have time to go
into detail but if you are interested in
that we can actually talk of that that's
it so next up is Matei Oh
you need to stay wired up you will be
back in in the panel
look at that we can manage files
occasionally all right all right thanks
so let's see yep I'm my taser hurry and
I'm also going to talk about
infrastructure for developing AI and
machine learning applications so I think
the the talks before really set the
stage for this because everyone's
already said that you know even though a
lot of work has gone into training
performance there are many other
problems that affect our ability to
build production application so I'm
going to talk a little bit about what
some of what I see as the problems and
some things that I'm working on and I'm
gonna talk from both a research
perspective and an industry perspective
cuz I've been spending some time in
industry as well to work on some of
these problems so the first thing I
wanted to start with is how building AI
powered applications is different from
traditional software and I think this
then gets you to the type of systems and
the types of problems you need so let's
just start by looking at that so first
of all let's look at what the goal is
when you're building the software in
traditional software the goal is usually
to meet some kind of functional
specification like if the user presses
this button you know the file is deleted
if they remove someone from the event
you know the thing goes away from that
person's calendar whatever it is so
that's what it is even the the goal in
machine learning I think is usually
different so in machine learning usually
it's not just a boolean thing does it
work or not if the goal is actually to
optimize some kind of metric like let's
say the accuracy or the click-through
rate or whatever it is and as a result
of that you're never really done with it
you know do you never say okay we're
finished with this machine learning
application you can always improve the
model and you constantly want to
experiment with new techniques and see
if you can make it better
if you improve that prediction accuracy
by 1% you know it's a huge difference in
revenue huge impact on user experience
whatever it is so that's one difference
second difference is what goes into the
quality of your application so in
traditional software the quality mostly
depends on your
code if you wrote the code correctly and
it matches the spec you're good and you
know they're all these tools for looking
at your code and validating it in
machine learning the quality also
depends a lot on the input data and also
to some extent on fungible things like
the training method and the tuning
parameters used and so on within the
algorithm but just by definition machine
learning is programs that generalize
from data so if you put in bad training
data it's not going to give you a good
result so that's the difference as well
you got a monitor and improve your
training data and then the final thing
is about debugging how to tell if it's
going on so in traditional software ok
debugging is hard but once you notice
something is going wrong it's fairly
mechanical you know you got a stack
trace you turn on a profiler whatever
you do is it's like it's a well
understood process to go through on the
other hand and machine learning the
models are often opaque and you know if
I just tell you this this model is miss
predicting this data point it's kind of
hard to tell what's happening or how to
improve it and then the data is also
more complex to look at so the big
question is okay if these AI and data
applications are going to be everywhere
what should be the infrastructure so we
developed them and hopefully I convinced
you that qualitatively pretty different
from other software and I'm going to
talk about these two perspectives so
with my academic hat on I work in this
lab Stanford Don that's focused on
infrastructure for machine learning and
I'm going to talk about you know
algorithms and abstractions to make
sense of these data driven applications
and then with my industry hat on I spent
some time at data breaks a startup
company and we're developing this open
source ml platform and ml platforms are
a concept that's well established in the
in the tech industry now it's a new type
of system to manage the lifecycle of ml
applications is very successful and I
think it's a very good area for research
as well like these are super useful and
I don't see anyone writing papers about
them ok so let's look at this I'm just
gonna talk about one example of a
problem and some work we did obviously I
don't have to
so the problem I'm going to talk about
is Quality Assurance
you've got your ml application but these
applications can fail in complex hard to
debug ways sorry for the overlap I think
the slides were copied and lost their
format so an example of that is these
Tesla cars multiple cars crashed into
these highway lane dividers in
California it was you know easy to
explain the behavior and I mean it was
easy to write about what the behavior
was but it's not clear why they did that
but they did this and another example
that's well known as these gender
classifiers would do very poorly for
dark-skinned people because they didn't
have a lot of maybe training data in
that case so these are just some
examples of problems so how can we test
applications and avoid these kind of
problems and the idea we're looking at
is taking software engineering
techniques and and basically applying
them to machine learning so and adapting
them to work with the ml training
process which involves you know data and
optimization and stuff like that
so one project that we started is simply
using assertions this is kind of the
first line of defense to monitor
applications is you have these boolean
statements and we're trying to see what
happens if you put assertions on top of
the output of a machine learning
application and we noticed in a lot of
cases when people have problems like the
ones described here it's actually easy
to describe the problem in terms of the
output of the application and you can
actually write an assertion just as a
program you know you don't need to do
computer vision and stuff to do the
assertion
so just as a simple example we worked on
video analytics and we noticed this
problem where you know the model detects
objects on some frames and not on our
days which we'll call flickering and
it's clearly a problem and you don't
need to know the internals of a model to
know that you know this behavior is
probably bad if an object just
disappears for one frame and comes back
so you could imagine writing an
assertion that you know this card
shouldn't flicker in and out and okay
maybe sometimes it's legitimate for them
to do so but definitely you don't want
this to fire too often and then were
actually
looking at how to use this to improve
the training process so you can use that
for monitoring that's kind of nice but
we're especially looking at feeding this
back into the training process of the
model and we found out that there are
some interesting ways to use them to get
a better model just based on you know
does it pass these assertions or not
so just actually those are the examples
of assertions we looked at various
domains there are a lot of kind of
consistency constraints you can have on
the output like for example lidar and
video should give you the same answer or
whatever and we tried using these in two
ways the first way is we tried using
them for active learning so if we in a
lot of cases you have to request new
data to be labeled and if we use
assertions to to select the data that we
want humans to label we get a better
score now this M AP metric is kind of
weird so it looks like it's not a huge
difference but the point seven one two
point six six is actually a you know a
significant difference there the other
thing we looked at is weak supervision
which is you can sometimes use the
assertion to fill in a guess at what the
label should have been and even though
it's not a perfectly accurate label you
can also use that in your training
process and get a better result and so
these are just two simple ways but they
result in basically kind of
qualitatively better you know detection
in this case this is with the flickering
assertion you can see before and after
that you know the model is just better
at detecting these guys so that's the
assertion part so the other thing I
wanted to talk about is in the industry
part and here I wanted to say that just
go here does basically you know people
are companies building hundreds of ml
applications successfully and the way
they do it is using these systems called
ml platforms so some examples are
Facebook's have been Lerner uber Michael
Angelo Google tf-x these are used to
build hundreds of applications
internally they're very successful and
so I think this is a type of system
that's important to look at and there
are a lot of cool research problems and
how to set this up and so the
interesting thing now is you know these
have successfully
accelerated machine learning in
companies but they've a they're limited
to a few algorithms in each company
usually and they're also limited to each
company's infrastructure so these
separate groups building their own
platform and we so one of the things I'm
involved in is this project called ml
flow which is to kind of take these
ideas and build an open-source and kind
of open interface ml platform that just
works with you know whatever software
people are using it's not specific say
to Google's infrastructure or to
Microsoft's or whatever else so we
launched this open-source project I
probably don't have time to show you all
the things in it but it's basically got
you know he producible projects
experiment tracking and also some
abstractions for deploying and
monitoring models and it's an
open-source project and we've seen a lot
of traction for it we started this last
summer last June and we have you know
over 100 contributors since including
actually Microsoft Azure ml team you
know our studio and many others so if
you want to learn about this space we
have a short paper on it and I also just
think it's a it's a very interesting
class of system to look at so that's
that's basically my thanks thank you ok
next up is janky and it's as you notice
we are moving from like the application
and developer tier closer and closer to
systems for it so ok take it away ok
good hello everyone my name is Chan Chan
show today I'm going to talk about my
perspective of you know what is the past
and future of machine learning systems
so I've been working on machine learning
system for a few years now and when we
when I talk about my sister I think it's
important to actually take a broader
scope and look back into you know what's
going on you know history or machinery
if you look back you'll find that
actually the machinery ever since we
started to do research on and as well as
1960s when we invited a version like
perception
and gbm's neuro-networks many of they
are actually getting vented before the
year 2000 around year 2000 one thing
happened is that the cloud revolution
actually the arrival of companies like
Google and Microsoft Facebook and
services like Wikipedia allows us to
generate and allow a large amount of
data and those data serves as rich sauce
for machine learning challenges and we
see challenges like Netflix challenge
image net and other challenge that
really opens a new area of each of a
Chris Mullin field today most of the
data sources come in a more diverse form
so you collect data from a watch from a
car and we will need to really find ways
to adjust this new diverse form of data
the big data really puts a huge pressure
on compute and we started to see the
arrive of cloud computing allows us to
actually make use of them and the
machine learning community started up
GPUs around 2006 and today GPUs to you
is one of the main house power for
processing machine learning workloads
and finally we started to see a trend of
more specialization has a power so we
want to we're building however like TP
use Microsoft's calipower project to
really use specialization to mention to
push machine run into a next stage so if
you look at machine learning our
intelligent application as ho you cannot
ignore all these factors machine
learning model the data and how Alice
three pillars that really drives the
machine learning forward and one of the
most important things though is that
they're still one missing ingredient
here and that ingredients machine
learning assistance 10 years ago I was
an undergrad intern actually I work on
deep learning by there and they have to
write CUDA code for 8 months in order to
put my model onto there and gtx 28 the
GPL
today i will have to write a few lines
python code and that was really thankful
to the arrival of machine learning
assistants start with some time we start
to see system like party spartan graph
layer for general-purpose graph
processing and data processing cycle
learn cafe actually boost a maximum
tensor form part of these are the
learning assistants are really enables
us to you know be able to
deploy lonely ideas in a fuel our school
and really help us to improve
productivity of researchers so I worked
on a few of those systems in my PhD and
one of the common themes that seeing in
the English systems are you know it's
really important to make those systems
scalable so they really you will be able
to take and handle all the big big data
set out there but also really make this
accessible so that more people can be
will be able to use it and we already
have heard speed talks about you know
these perspectives you know talks that
would we have here however if you look
at current learning assistants one of
the things we find that's really
troubling is that you know while we are
building systems that enables machine
learning one of our toad fact is that
let us we know spent a lot of
engineering effort to optimize the
assistance and this is okay for big
companies but as a graduate student I
spent three years there and oh I don't
want to do that anymore so the questions
like you know can we actually do a bit
of change here since we are building
cisterna enables machine learning that
are intelligent can we use these machine
learning algorithm to then come back and
optimize those systems well the answer
is yes and that is something that I am
trying to advocate and working on in a
past three years so this is the new
paradigm called learning based learning
system that not only uses machine
systems to enable machine learning but
also build machine learning algorithm
the optimized insistence and as a result
we can spend less engineering effort to
optimize those so I'm going to tell you
but in particular this is no TVM that
tries to do more of automation that
enables deployment of different into all
kind of powered platforms so the problem
we are trying to solve
nowadays is that now we have a huge
spectrum of machine learning frameworks
and want to deploy them to all kind of
powers including your CPU your GPU
mobile devices our PJs and tv-like
platforms and that's a huge gap between
those frameworks and however and and our
platforms so if you look at what
existing frameworks - what they are
doing is that they will represent
mutations in what we call how about
their flow graphs and where each of a
color no Chris point to some operation
like you know contains the convolution
is a measure some application in order
flow down into a low level higher device
we need to map your shop data into a low
level R ring or case the media writer
library cos you do the problem of this
traditional approach of learning system
is there for every color note here we
have to present a library core in a
low-level libraries that translate to
like three engineers at least they are B
there will be more than three engineers
who spend a lot of time optimizing those
colors node and as you know that you
know machine learning is evolving field
and we will always try to add new color
node here to introduce a diversity of
workers or if you are system programming
you want to see like I want to take some
of the node here and I can perform
operator fusion to fuse them together to
gives you a faster computation because
you can reduce the amount of group run
shipping into global memory the problem
now is that you know this blue node no
longer exists in the low-level libraries
and so what do you do so you can ask in
video to say hey give me this group you
know that will mean there's you know
another months or another year usually
actually we did have experience asking
and to add a new operators and they
typically took them and are yet or you
can hire engineer to do that if you
multiply that by an amount of you know
how are back annual support you can
imagine is a very engineering has a
process so learning based learning is
such that aim to replace those human
based engineering effort by a machine
learning based automatic program
optimizer I don't have time to go into
details on how we do it but I will give
you a sense on you know why you know why
do you need this approach and what's the
benefit of this approach intuitively we
are trying to use automated solution to
compete with engineers but you know
usually engineers are smart so why can
we use lonely Irish into our performance
here's a bio use the benchmark exact
example to show like know what could
happen here so here we are comparing end
to end depending were closing inference
results where our baselines are backed
by engineering optimized libraries if
you use TV I'm you can find there we can
actually get better for for
one takeaway is that your own standard
benchmarks there is some improvement but
the most exciting thing is that you know
there's a 3x gapping here comparing
against typical early model with human
generic version so this is the model
used by deep mind to play at higher
games and the reason there's a there's a
3x gap is because you know people care
more about classic classifying cards
versus playing games or in other words
the resonators are seven benchmarks that
engineers spend a lot of time optimizing
on while we talk to our customers most
of them care about non-standard were
close this is where machine learning and
the automated solution kind of shrunk
because we can automate all this process
and another good news is that we can use
the same solution and use it to optimize
a wide spectrum of how we're back hands
without having to design specialization
on them so another interesting thing is
that you know besides the optimization
of CPU and GPU auw we are also building
an open-source our solution allows us to
you have open source our design I see
any drivers that allows us to explore
the design of new AR Howard and combine
that with the with the TVM compiler and
we have bunch of improvement on that so
to give you a sense on you know the
takeaways or my take off you know the
current and future of machine learning
most of the machine learning system we
have nowadays are trying to push for
making things scalable and accessible
and this you are very important cm
nowadays but I see that there's a
another to interesting factor first of
all I want to build learning assistant
are more intelligent so we can automate
away many of the engineer effort and we
can make the adapt to more wide spectrum
of how our devices and secondly we want
to build a full stack solution so that
we can build compilers that works with
new type of powers and optimize across
the stack to gives the best performance
and that's an animatronic thank you
thank you
[Applause]
so let me see whether we can pull this
trigger the file management one more
time okay that's the kicker okay next
time thank you and the microphone is
working right okay very good so as you
have seen and Marcos mentioned earlier
the talks have been going from how to
make machine learning easier for the
user platforms now compilation how to
deal with hardware and now we come to
the end that is actually hardware so
this is what I may be talking about
so I'm Gustavo lonesome for MIDI aids
and I have been doing for quite a while
now my background is in data bases
distributed system very traditional
computer science but I have been looking
into her world for a long time and the
reason why I have been doing this is
because there is something that
especially if you come from the software
side of things
the desacralization that is very
important that people come to is that
computers and software and these studies
caching I can give you a whole lecture
about it right are very very much tied
to the phenomenal model of computing
this affects not only the architecture
obviously because those are the
computers that we have today but more
importantly it also effects the
programming languages it affects the
algorithms it affects the way we think
about computing now for a long time that
has worked very well the problem today
is that this is very very inefficient
when you're dealing with amounts of data
on the type of computations that are
involved especially in AI machine
learning and all those things and
they're efficient in many ways is not
only time and you have seen the previous
talks have been mentioning in computing
things for machine learning right it
takes a long time but there is trimming
efficient in terms of course the number
of resources this is what we have the
cloud of course Microsoft Google Amazon
are very happy because people needs to
have hundreds of machines to run these
things but this is highly inefficient
and cost a lot of energy cost a lot of
computing and it's only that we have to
resort to these infrastructures as you
have rightly pointed out because we
don't have a better solution so if an
easy sort of the theme here the future
of work
as some people claimed we are going to
have machine learning and better on
almost everything that we do every day
we really need to change the way we
compute because it is not going to
happen with the platforms that we have
today so at this point for no man with
this the guy who is there right I just
want to say that he studied ETH of
course Alexander he studied there was in
the 20s there was no computer science he
studied Chemical Engineering and he was
a study on the same building where
computer science is today so it's
somewhat ironic that the people in the
building are trying to get rid of
following money now when I said delivery
in the computation power that we need
right will require to rethink things
from the bottom up I just want to give
you in the time that we have and then we
can discuss more than the panel I just
want to give you the basic idea of what
I mean and then give you a very brief
very briefly an example so at the end of
the day we are talking and you have also
mentioned this right we are talking
about Big Data and the problem with big
data is that the moment that the data
starts moving around in your system
doesn't matter whether it is the cloud
or a single computer in your laptop then
you already loose this is highly
inefficient so if the data is gonna have
to move and typically this is what needs
to happen and something useful needs to
happen as the data moves so in essence
you have to start thinking about
computing as something where every
element of the system where the data
goes through or is actually sitting
becomes an active component there are
many versions of these people talked
about in their world data processing and
near memory data processing in memory
data process in a smart storage smart
networking as marnix
there are many versions of this but in
essence in the future we will have
computing platforms if we can call them
this that way we are not going to be
just the traditional CPU with some
stories or even in the cloud the data
comes from the network you take it to
memory you go through the caches get to
the registers and eventually something
usual happens this is not the way we are
like to go onto Computing's
let me just give you one example of
course being a Microsoft you have to
mention this which actually shows what
is happening in reality this is not just
me from academia making this up
Microsoft now
this is Martinique so there is an FBA
and race equal the blood working part is
actually implemented the reason why they
do these several reasons but the most
important one is that CPUs are just too
efficient to manage at the moment the
networking part that you need to have in
a cloud computing platform and then it's
better off to actually put it on on a
smart Nick and that saves course for
doing something else so this is just one
example there are many others is also
what has led Google to actually
implement the TPU because computing
these type of models become so expensive
that you know what the heck let's just
go and do a processor specialized on it
so I just want to talk for the next two
minutes and then I'll conclude our
project our eta is together with my
colleague Timothy Roscoe the Assessor
will give you an idea of the type of
thinking that we have so in essence we
have gone from being software people to
building our own computers to try to
address some of these problems this is a
machine that we call Enzian when you
have his standard course in this case
arm course for the air of them selves
are great and then we have a large FPGA
and what is interesting is that we in
this machine we have actually reversed
the roles of the CPU and the accelerator
so we actually have half a terabyte of
memory on the FPGA and there is only 128
gigabytes on the course the idea is that
most of the processing is actually going
to happen on the FPL why Marcus stole my
pitch right a war for 9 month because
the type of things that you can do on
the FPGA is highly parallel processing
on anything that moves around in the
form of a stream so this actually fits
very well with machine learning it fits
very well with a cloud for instance
where you're actually getting data
either from memory or you're getting it
from storage or it comes from the
network and then you can actually take
advantage of the FPGA to process the
data as it goes through and then you can
also use the CPU for the type of things
that you can actually not accelerate or
that you can actually you know change
because still you still need to run
Linux or a standard operating system and
you need to manage a whole platform so
it's the type of systems that I think in
the future are going to become
increasingly more interesting and of
course I was very happy with your talk
because that of course the challenge of
these things is how do we build the
wholistic so a big part of our research
is not only act illegally in this
machine to run it's actually building
the whole stack from the very low level
system aspects all the way to the
applications so that he actually becomes
easier to use these things for instance
one of the things that we're doing for
those in the room who are really
interested in too deeply into the system
side we're implementing our own cache
coherency protocol in order to explore
to what extent cache coherency is a good
idea in these systems
we also have very heavy networking on
the other side so we also wanted to use
this platform to explore to what extent
we can actually extend cache coherency
across machines in a distributed system
by taking advantage of the fact that we
can implement all these things on FPGA
and we are removing a lot of the
overhead of the CP so with that I
finished it's actually something that is
already running and operating this is
the prototype that we have this was
actually wired by hand and by the end of
the year we will have the balls and the
prototypes and we hope that very soon
we'll have a cluster of 40 50 of these
machines running on 88 the idea is to
make this all open-source for people to
on the system side to actually play with
it and of course we have people I'd say
and other people are idiots who are very
interested in using this platform for
machine learning but anybody who has
questions or want to discuss what we're
doing this I'm happy to answer now that
we have the panel okay that's good all
of our panelists to to come up here and
Marcus is also gonna sit on the panel
and sort of represent another industrial
point of view I'm selfishly going to ask
a question or two at the start but then
it would be great if we could be more
interactive and if you could think of
some questions to ask and then I have
just one that I want to ask at the end
here so so the first question I have for
all of you as sort of as I was saying in
my part of the talk that I feel like
we're really in the early days where you
know a long way off from where I hope
that we actually get to
and I think as was presented in sort of
several of the talks you know one of the
the big recent breakthroughs we've had
is to make deep learning very accessible
is you know the last step was getting
the GPUs and and hardware that actually
enabled us to train these models and
make models that are usable in practice
and so my question to you is what's the
the change in the ecosystem or the
innovation of the research ideas that's
going to result in the next big
breakthrough that's gonna result in a
major step function change is it
hardware again is it
what tin she was sort of implying where
we should all just go meta and start
generating systems that generate systems
or you know what's what's kind of the
next big thing here so if I just go
first because there was the last one to
talk about the hardware
I think hardware is a component that you
can not about Hardware has to change I
think what we have for now in machine
learning comes you have mentioned in
fright because of the advances in
hardware the advances of GPUs in fact
machine learning is driving now the
hardware industry toward very large
sustained on the new generation of GPUs
and no longer graph processing unit are
actually machinery processing units but
is of course it's not enough you need to
change the way you do machine learning
we need to look at the algorithms we
understand what is in there right I mean
that right now we use if you want to
call it very successful but we we use
very primitive forms of machine learning
and treatment of the data and the way we
actually process these things that also
has to change but doing those things
will require hard work because it
requires a huge amount of
experimentation so you read the two
things and hardware is one requirement
that we thought it is knowable yeah I
guess you might so I think it's not only
how if so if you look at successful
media I think the main seems and main
reason I still remember like 10 years
ago for me to choose to buy a media cars
because of CUDA because you know it's
there is a programming model that allows
us to somehow although it's harder than
programming or CPU but is still
relatively easy to program and allows
people to move all those bits onto the
how ourselves
there's a child of beauty more
specialized power but in the mean time
it also makes the programming really
hard and I believe you know besides
having better powers it's really
important to also enable more flexible
software so we'll be able to move all
those bits again on through this new
have a house okay I get to say something
too cool I think there's a view machine
learning as it stands right now is a
really really frustrating success
because there are areas in this world
where we know the largest impact can be
had let's say the medical domain right
if we had a giant table with everyone's
medical data and their treatment and the
outcome I'm very convinced that we could
create better outcomes on average for
everyone if we had that table but in
society that's not acceptable right we
don't want to have a place where you
where anyone can go and say I won't hire
that person because they have a high
risk of heart attack in the next three
months right so whatever we can do and
there are approaches like a morphic
encryption multi-party function
evaluation and all of those things from
cryptography or maybe others that can
enable that domain which I think can be
the biggest impact that that machine
learning can have on under the life of
most people I think that's the
technology that we need to to make the
big next big step function yeah you
asked you know what will be the next
kind of technical change that will
increase the impact of machine learning
sorry there's two different ones so
first of all if you want to make current
applications better in some way sure it
will be you know research into the ML
techniques and hardware but I think if
you want to see more applications and
democratize machine learning it's
definitely the platform so the stuff I
talked about the ml platforms now mean
that you know and these in these web
companies using them there are now
hundreds of you know application
features that are powered by machine
learning where they used to be just one
or two before I know Justin ubereats for
example I think there are about 20
different machine learning models to you
know recommend the food to you tell you
the estimate of how long it will take to
come suggest apply suggest a discount
all that stuff and you can't scale to
like this level of MLP
features without a different way of
developing the applications and they're
very simple models and stuff the key is
getting them to keep running well yeah
yeah so I agree with all of this yeah so
like I'm just I to that right like in my
personal opinion so what would what
could lead to the next big change right
so let me talk about one thing that I
believe could cause a change but that's
not really technical
I think what's not going to happen that
become really interesting it's actually
the scale of similar scale of adaptation
of motion or nyan right so think about
after five years if we have maybe one
like 1,000 10,000 in real-world machine
learning applications we can put them
together and really try to understand
what emotion learning really is and what
about abstraction we should be able to
support machine learning I think exactly
like a link to another change from the
motion and system side okay thanks
everyone um a lot of you I guess are
putting your money where your mouth is
and working in the area you think would
be very high impact so that's great
let me ask you about an area that I
think none of you are really working in
but it's very interesting which is
programming languages right they're
starting to be some work in this area
what do you think is is our programming
language is part of the story is Python
always going to be the primary thing
just you know I'd love to hear your
thoughts on programming languages so in
programming languages of course I mean
everything that we have said is a very
important component I mean you need the
applications understand machine learning
you need the platforms to be able to run
and you need the compilation you need
the programming languages you need the
hardware to run it right we thought that
our programming languages is an
interesting question because I think
let's ignore machine learning and her
reservation for a second machine
programming languages became a problem
in the moment that we went to multi-core
this is very well known forget machine
learning forget hardware acceleration
because we don't know how to deal with
parallel
it's very difficult to do now how are
things going to be or how the how the
fact that we have a Hitler universe
hardware now we have a CPU we have a GPU
have an FPA we have a TPU this is the
Stuber in the cloud well nobody knows
right coming out so there are advances
you know it's a spark a programming
language well just know it's a platform
I think the notion of programming
language in the traditional sense is
going to disappear you're going to have
things that are closest to the platforms
that we're seeing and this is where
people are going to program these things
I don't think you can actually specify
the full-blown complexity of the type of
applications are we developing today
using traditional programming language I
do think that you know PR you and
cherish PL have a rolling model in
machine learning and so if you look at
like tensorflow
or pi college many of that or like when
we're talking about like a program
abstraction of the API abstractions
sometimes if you alleviate that it could
be like a programming language if you
look at like Tosh script and where
everybody is heading a suite for
tensorflow
and human TVM we have like we have a PL
group who are working on a Halawa are
called relay that they are designing for
them but what is the better type system
that allows you to express those
multi-dimensional tensile constraints
and helps you to generate better code
and many of the wisdom seeing
traditional program language might help
another example is that doing automatic
differentiation be able to differential
a cause control flows and recursions
that were really being able better
express entity of a program that will
enable better yep so I basically wants
to say what chunky just said about how
we can integrate
machine learning operators into the
languages themselves another thing that
comes to mind is when we talk about
programming languages and machine
learning what we've discussed so far and
I don't want to kind of talk for the
people after me is about how do we make
the process of machine learning itself
better expressed but in reality there's
also this problem of how do I get my
model into my application all right and
applications are written in Java or.net
in JavaScript that's roughly the world
all right and notably there is like
almost
no overlap between that and the machine
learning world today right machine
learning models are done in are in
Python and applications are written in
another language and we are all quickly
building bridges between them right and
it might just be that the true solution
is hey the world needs to write all of
the applications in Python or all of
machine learning needs to be done in
dotnet which I would be greatly in favor
of but that to me is like this chasm
that we have to overcome to to get more
people be capable of doing doing machine
learning I think like basically
tensorflow fighter which are programming
languages in some sense
yeah yeah so I think I mean it's op
depends on your audience right so like
for the audio audience is like data
scientists I think one interesting
problem is if you look at the language
for data processing right now right so
there's Python but there's also sequel
right which is declarative and code for
so I think after a couple years like we
we point to understand which components
of the machine learning program should
be made an you know declarative way
right maybe we can have the counter
profit of sicko
to help our data scientist to program
motion during you a much higher level
abstraction okay great thank you
well I will share this wonderful panel
with all of you what questions do you
have and we have people who will bring a
microphone to you so raise your hand if
you have a question for the panel thank
you great panel one thing I was very
impressed by the work on the
architecture I believe it was called
Elysium set thank you okay thank you and
and I was struck by fact that I've seen
similar work at Microsoft around the
believe project brain wave is what it's
called now and they now have a
deployment across a sure and I'm curious
about the state of the art of its
compiler stack that because it faces the
same problem that a lot of you have just
addressed in terms of the complexity of
the compiler stack is that up to the
point where it is
now competitive with the rest of the
word so sort of Microsoft question so we
need a Microsoft person answer I
honestly don't know I think it's hard
still to program for FPGAs but I'm not
working in that area I I will speak from
my perception which is slightly maybe
out of date but I think even people
working on the project were
underestimated early on how hard it is
to create an entirely sort of new
ecosystem and a new stack and
particularly for a very different type
of computing technology and so I think
they've come a long way but it is a very
hard problem so I I can only comment I
cannot comment about Microsoft but other
companies that have gone this way right
they have had significant difficulties
building the stack that they need to use
these things right because it's not just
the hardware you need a compiler you
need the language you need interfaces to
other things right I mean an operating
system that knows how to call these
things so you actually need to work on
the whole stack and that's the big
challenge but everybody recognizes that
he needs to be done now what is the
actual state of Microsoft but I think
there are enough people here maybe
outside this room that can actually
answer that question but I think this is
the call to like what was so great about
CUDA that I think NVIDIA has done a
great job of really trying to bring
their stack up to where it was actually
usable can we get a microphone here
thank you
I mean a long history of attention
between performance and productivity I
mean this this panel is nominally but
programmers productivity but you got it
into performance in the reality is that
we only have one success story in many
failure and the success story is data
parallelism and everything else just a
reality it's been a failure people have
tried to have all kind of power power
you know for example parallelizing
compilers we're out they were still
using MPI so the only thing we've
succeeded is longer data what we had one
success basically is a I think sim D has
been only success in parallelism so part
of the question is you know yes we could
all kind of esoteric way to increase
performance but we have to balance the
productivity valves to the performance
and I think that's a tension that's not
going to go away I disagree I think
you're correct at the level of one
machine may be exceeded those type of
things as is the successful parallelism
whether it is the best way to do is a
different question but the cloud is
parallelism is brute force parallelism
is very primitive form of parallelism
but what these platforms give you and
you know Hadoop spark MapReduce all
those four things what they give us a
way to Antoni paralyzing is a very large
scale is very trivial parallelism is for
embarrassingly parallel problems and in
tarragon I agree with you that's as far
as we are so but that's as far as we're
so I agree I mean we need to come up
with better ways of doing this but there
has been also some progress on
multi-threading right if you look at
async await as language constructs that
makes stuff that used to be difficult
very accessible to a lot of people I
think and just say this task may take
long I put a sink in front of the
function and I await an answer and it
can write code as if I had the answer
already that is a complete step function
change of how many people can
successfully put something into a threat
that they're before couldn't so we see a
lot more usage of task
level parallelism as well it's not just
data parallel if I may
following up on your thing I mean I
think one of the problems behind our
inability to deal with parallelism in
computer science is this phone know my
model
if you look at programming languages the
way we think about code the way we think
about algorithms is extremely sequential
we're actually the only ones doing this
so if you talk to electrical engineers
whenever they do a Silkwood right I mean
they perfectly understand everything
there is active at the same time there
is no there is nothing sequential
interpret and they are trained in that
particular way well in computer science
we're actually training the opposite way
we are trying to think sequentially our
everything now that doesn't solve the
problem we need to start thinking in
different ways but I think that there
are there is progress being made but we
are really at the beginning I mean think
about these data flow architectures that
is much more parallel while you're
thinking about programs that what we
have done until now again providing you
simple large carnality but there is a
step in the right direction now we need
to turn this into compilers that are
more intelligent and do better things
right I mean I saw what I think yes
that's correct that's the problem that
we need to solve paralyzing and if we
talk about the attention in general
between just productivity and
performance
I mean compilers is obviously a huge
success story here right most of us can
write assembly language that is as
performance as their compiler could do
and so there's also just a theme around
intelligent optimization and I think
there's definitely potential for us to
improve performance through that kind of
channel as well and obviously that
productivity is something that people
always want as long as under the
constraint that you want to get things
done the reason that people switch to
GPU is that cpu is no no longer possible
to actually retrieve them assuring house
we won and they are saying that you know
nowadays machinery and sound is always
trading they are modeling in three days
because even if a double the computer
they will try bigger models and in that
case you know you will find that there
were always people who want to push the
extremes and actually get more powers
and I'll get more specialization because
there's a demand on
so and and you know you can all simply
trade that for project productivity
because the annual your job might take
six days or like a month to come
hi everyone great panel I really enjoyed
it
um I have a question kind of towards our
first speaker uh I think and I mentioned
something at the very beginning that
your research interest was also in how
to make ml usable for non-expert users
and I'm interested in that and that the
people you're working with our domain
experts in their various areas but also
in regards to the entirety of all these
talks this is a complicated process with
all the infrastructure and the
frameworks and the deployment and the
various aspects of this process how much
of that do you think becomes a
requirement for domain experts of the
future and how much of that should
really be abstracted away for them and
the caveat there is maybe they don't
realize that you know they really should
be randomizing their data maybe they
have misrepresented samples maybe
they're deploying at a scale that they
don't understand where do you think that
trade-off lies and maybe that's
addressed to everyone as well yeah so so
I mean I mean it's right so like like
one sneeze after maybe five or ten years
what will happen or another things like
today or in the next three years what
will happen right so it's in the next
three years you know every tuple is you
need to have access to some low-level
details right so example the need to be
able to split Union and testing quickly
and I cannot tell you how often they get
that wrong right so they have a time
series the cap in the middle and just a
move on right so I mean I mean I mean
the next three years before we really
understand what is a comment is
untighten full-motion learning if they
want to use too much in earnest they
cannot need to understand a little bit
about the basic requirement and into
like running at the data does about
science right but I think the next few
years tissue the move away from knowing
what is tensorflow
and and that's a hope right so and I'm
taking to move away from knowing what a
GPO is right so so I think that's could
happen in next few years if you are
talking about like even like like a
longer term right so after we understand
what machine learning really is and what
is the abstraction of motion or Nia
maybe Jake can actually that maybe we
can't is like after we know the data
mode of motion journey so we can do
automatics
optional intestine right but before that
is very hard for us to abstract that
level of detail where you from them
that's my opinion one thing I wanted to
put here is there are a lot of
application domains where you can just
do stuff end to end where they don't
have to you know explicitly use machine
learning so and there are some really
successful ones like that all these you
know kind of cognitive services you put
in some text and it tells you whether
it's like offensive or whatever it is
that that are widely used another
example of something that I think is a
is a good abstraction and anyone can use
this search so think of like adding
search into an application you just
install a library like solar it just
kind of works you don't need to know
about all the information retrieval
research in there and I've also seen
people do similar things with with
anomaly detection or prediction there's
this library called profit for example
from Facebook that can extrapolate many
times of times time series so I think
these will you know it'll be interesting
to see when you can just use these
voices telling them okay well you know
go take a machine learning class and
like learn you know what a model is what
it is and all that yeah they're on the
same line I'm and this might be shocking
to the academics in the room but machine
learning and practice is not as rich in
variants as in research so every company
on the planet has a multi class text
classification problem can we please
just solve that once and tell them how
to train it alright that every company
on the planet can sort the emails can
route their tickets all of that right so
that's kind of in the same way in
weights it goes beyond the coronary
service goes to the whole training part
and everything right that you can just
solve once another thing is and I think
that's that's also underappreciated in
in the current line of work is they
different personas that deal with data
so there is the developer persona
there's the data scientist there's a
data engineer there's a data analyst and
in my work I came to the shocking
conclusion that they speak different
languages they encode them all in
English but they speak different
languages and it's very important for us
as at least the practitioners are to
build
tools that speak the language of the
target audience all right
so for instance machine learning in
sequel makes sense for data analysts
makes absolutely no sense for developers
developers want imperative code right
machine learning in Python makes all the
sense for a data scientist in tools in
pies makes absolute sense doesn't make
sense for our financial app developer
right they write their stuff in Java or
dot an RN C shop so translating it into
the various domains is a thing that we
absolutely should do both in terms of
language that they speak and in terms of
application domain okay so I'm gonna ask
the last question as I told you I would
but this one I'm also willing to take
answers from the audience what can those
of us in industry do to help accelerate
research progress in this area money and
magic will happen okay I like that
that's easy
anything else how many from the audience
who come from the University I agree
that funding is an important component
please raise your hand we have data we
have customers we have a lot of
different things you have everything you
need except money I think well what will
be very very useful is to actually get
honest datasets and honest use cases
that are separated from the hype of
these things right I mean I hope so you
get you know all these constant stream
of huge successes on these and are and
we can do this quicker than you would
never get about you never hear about the
problems the things that don't work the
things that are not perfect right I mean
that so getting more information on what
works what doesn't what are the problems
and so forth that will be very useful so
that the work that the universities to
become more becomes more relevant also
foreign companies right kind of
questions of that how would you like to
get that information because I'm part of
a group that does part of that by just
publishing papers on the problem and and
our solution so far but what what form
should that take it so
there are groups to do this there are
others that don't there are companies
that publish papers and the papers are
hugely misguided miss guiding so you
know my group I tell my students not to
read papers from a particular company
until I explained to them what the
company is claiming because it's
actually not true what they're saying so
you know I know that this is being
filmed so I don't mention companies so
it depends on the groups depends on the
companies depends on on what is a setup
but I think that separating the
commercial hype the marketing hype from
the actual technical problem that you're
solving that will already be a huge huge
step I think besides like financial
support and other things I find that was
very helpful at least in my research is
that companies supporting open source
from universities and because you know
in that way we get contributors and
actually trying to build something that
our research can be directly deployed
into product of the companies and now
that's also another way of getting any
other ask if not then we will thank our
panel for their great talks and answers
in the panel and thank you all for
coming
[Applause]